residen evil 7 biohazard so there been a
few updates Twilight is the new South a
new demo but update the beginning our
demo with like there's a little more to
see in the mansion that we saw from the
first original incarnation that demo and
then at Gamescom I play the lantern demo
and Rob you recently just what yesterday
went to capcom to see a lasting demo
last week last week yes he lantern demo
idea with VR PSV ah right now so I don't
know what do you think now that you've
actually played it like leaving aside
the vr four now what do you think of
resident evil as someone who I don't
think is super into that series right
sure yeah and this this demo was very
much different right you're playing
along the lines of a cat and mouse and
you're being chased by one of those
crazy Louisiana cannibal nutjobs yep so
you're that's the stairs I we all know
and love you're you're not taking any
breathers in this demo so I think it to
have any of those like open world or not
open world but like exploration elements
of the other demos but yeah you're being
chased the whole time and very much a
[ __ ] esque vibe I felt a lot of
similarities like you know isolate alien
isolation or even like outlast sure um
it was it was a little bit was pretty
gripping I was into it don't say pt
though I will not nothing like it the
sore spot the prey ads for the premises
the lantern I guess you could say is
this woman of that that family after the
name of them but they're Baker's shakers
that's right yes oh she is just chasing
you through this mansion and you're
going under floorboards you go in
between walls she's got a lantern that
is what you need in order to pick her
out from the dim lit mansion and yeah it
was it was pretty it's pretty insane i
was i was into it um and probably more
so with the VR mm-hmm I I did play it
again without it but the VR element
really had me going I mean I'm one to
like fall for jump scares and very good
footage right now just run Rob's
jump-scare coming up this might not be a
boo I think we have some audio later on
but yeah there's one moment where I
freaked out
I mean yeah just to be in a immersed
horror element where you just like being
chased and you have to go behind boxes
and peek around that's where the VR
element like shined sure and and more so
than anything else I feel like was being
able to yeah you're kind of
circumventing a box and i'm looking
between the cracks of the box and and it
helped it was even like a plus to have
that because I could see her easier as I
moved opposed to like looking I could I
could still look you know you have that
that freedom to kind of peer around
smaller areas of sight and yeah of
course it's there's nothing like looking
back and seeing this woman I'm gonna
find you running at you god that's the
thing this so obviously this is another
flashback within the game so this is not
the main protagonist to be playing this
is like a VHS tape you come across and
the thing I found with this when I
played a couple months ago is that there
weren't many jumpscares there's
obviously the one you're talking about
and it does happen when you turn around
and she's right there when you don't
know it obviously the lantern kind of
gives her away which that's the point
makes a little more ominous but it was
just like a slow build of tension and
dread that really drove this forward
because at certain point each cell like
old-school residen evil puzzles but
she's still this constant threat kind of
like the Nemesis if you played a
resonable 3 actually the UH in this demo
I'm not gonna vouch for the game writing
like that but the demo actually the one
puzzle that they showed it felt like
actually that was a breather or not now
I think about it it kind of paused you
find the puzzle as she's chasing you but
then you go back to where the puzzle is
applied and then the game kind of breaks
and it's like oh I thought she was still
like free roaming while you're solving
it now there was definitely the first
time I did I took forever actually uh
she definitely wasn't around but yeah
those are kind of huh did she catch you
yeah couple times Oh a couple times
where I'm like opening trying to open a
locked door you know you it was very
much a path it was on Rails of where
else was to be going but um you know it
was a little bit of a trial and error
there's one door that she came out of it
I imagined to go into uh didn't open and
she did there are you on yeah she's got
the key cuz that's like one of the doors
you can let her walk through seating it
behind her kind of from what I remember
hmm but
one who is not like like pno you played
the series for a while and you're really
familiar the series as someone who's not
particularly familiar with it how does
this like are you optimistic about this
game because obviously we haven't played
much more than that we did see the
trailer when they're actually showing
like gunplay now and actual a little
more there's like just like policemen
zombie in a garage from what i remember
it was more of like a suburban setting
that we saw there so maybe that's part
of the main game i don't know if it's a
flashback but as someone who's not
familiar with a series does this kind of
strike you as something that you'll want
to jump into or is this something that's
kind of I mean without nostalgia and
play what do you think of it I thought
it was yeah it was really fun I mean it
makes me want to play all these other
demos because I'm what I'm hoping this
game is it's you know bits and pieces of
what you know they've been showing in
different levels like it'd be cool to
you know change a corner and then have
this ride for a period of time like I
like that idea um which is what it
sounds like because yeah those those
tapes right that sort of put everything
in that context mmhmm yeah structurally
it sounds like a cool story telling
mechanics like a book haunted by chuck
palahniuk ER like there are any number
of frame stories where the main
narrative like contains these shorter
stories in between so I think they were
saying some of those VHS tapes you come
across will actually be related to the
main protagonist others will just be
these tangential things that kind of
flesh out the Baker's for instance or
the house you're in or the cabin you're
in the part of the marsh you're in but
that's what is really kind of pushing
this game home for me as of now it's
going to be on january but right now i'm
pretty optimistic because i think
resonable does need kind of shot in the
veins especially following six the last
numbered entry and then you played
umbrella core recently which they
removed the res evil name from but it
was still resonate booking it's like
Metal Gear survived but just exactly
spite that was the segue I should have
used but that and that was not a good
game those got fast pace 3v3 tactical
shooters show yeah so this is you know
they say they're trying to return to the
horror roots with puzzles the puzzle
they showed in this one is very I don't
know it was pretty you'd have to be
pretty oblique not to solve it ya know
it was pretty easy but I don't know it
it yeah the demo felt like very much
segmented again I was like okay puzzle
time again I'm curious to know how these
all mesh because I think there was there
was something there there was something
cool about
um you know you're underneath the
floorboards and you find a note you know
there are bits of like story that I'm
definitely intrigued and I want to know
more about I just wonder how how is that
gonna be delivered because that was the
thing is I I wanted to explore but you
can't like you're being chased so as
long as there are successful ways of
transitioning between this area like I
mean I guess you could you could say
okay maybe I'll go back and play this
section again but i don't know like you
like it won't i say is during these
moments of where you're being chased
like they should i don't know how the on
earth they could like put these moments
of like okay now you're now you're able
to like look around and read a note or
some like that i just found it was hard
to explore again like i just wonder how
they're gonna mesh all this together I
got yeah this was definitely more of a
set-piece kind of a very scripted Thea
she was traveling along these certain
paths and then when she heard something
if you stood up and ran too fast she
would kind of chase you right so I was
you know like makes you crouch the whole
time and then right you were saying you
were kind of worried when you're under
the floorboard your kind of hunching
over that was in the VR though right
that was very cool yeah you know just
inherently you just wanted a crouch cuz
if there was a lot of the moments of
like claustrophobic vibes it was like oh
god this new notes she's definitely
above Mia when is she gonna like come
out and get me um it was cool it was it
was it was a fun little roller coaster
yeah yeah and then like that's what I'm
saying the big mystery remains and I
think we'll be seeing more of in the
coming months before January exciting I
think Capcom is pretty aware that people
are worried they haven't seen much
gunplay so I think that's they were some
people at capcom were saying that's why
they included it in the trailer reasoner
worried about seeing the thing that
they've said the series has too much of
yeah okay yeah exactly so they're saying
like okay now it's not a resin evil game
it's just going off PT and that's a sore
spot because resin evil 7 was already in
development before PT was ever a thing
and then you know you have like people
like kawada saying no this isn't
something where like piggybacking off of
but like outlast too does the same kind
of horror as well so it's almost
becoming like this new know this new
trend in horror this is first person
atmospheric narrative-driven kind of as
opposed to the actual survival but the
new trailer in resin will 7 that longer
one that showed more like survival
elements and they're talking about
there's going to be the green herbs that
you know like for healing there's going
to be guns that you probably too
serve a mo I mean it really comes down
to inventory management right that is
the only aspect of survival that ever
existed in Resident Evil because you can
find enough stuff you just couldn't
carry it all with you yeah if they they
can get that down if they can make this
sense of discovery like think back to
the original resident evil right like
when you finally solve enough puzzles
and you unlocked a new part of the
mansion or new section outside the
mansion that made all of the tedium of
going in circles in that one area worth
it because then you you've really
appreciated this this new place and
again the fixed cameras gave you a very
strong sense of tension and atmosphere
if it can just do those three things I
think this game will be a good Resident
Evil game despite everything else that
it does like I think those are the
pillars that need to happen so you do
you think it'll be structurally set up
kind of like a Metroid where you're
backtracking a lot and then to unlock
these new areas I don't even want to say
been charted I mean no like the
obviously the more apt comparisons like
resonable 12 yeah yes I do think that if
they are consciously trying to you know
yes do something new but do it in the
framework of a thing that people have
told them that they love and they want
more of it would behoove them to go back
and really break down what made those
games successful and why and impart that
knowledge into the new formula doesn't
it's gonna be interesting to see because
you look at the pattern it was like 1 2
3 where that very the third person fixed
camera inventory management then 456 are
much more third-person action driven you
wonder if like seven eight nine I don't
know if like how long it's going to go
but you wonder if they're going to stick
with this for a while until the next
thing comes along or whether Capcom
knows what it's doing at this point or
not there was a weird period of
transition I think for gaming and
especially international game
development where Japanese developers
are trying to make games to suit the
West what they thought Westerners wanted
because our market is bigger and growing
where Japan is shrinking and that's
probably why we got a lot of those
action games i'm just guessing here but
it seems to be that was sort of the
right time in place for them to do that
sort of thing or so they thought I feel
like those days are done like I feel
like now they're almost starting from
scratch and looking to the Past won't
really inform us about where they're
going I think this game is really
setting the future for the series like
the tone for it and who knows what's
gonna happen yeah I hope it's great like
it's seen everything so far she was
really promising I haven't seen anything
apart from a few like technical things
related to VR like Crouching I was told
there's not really a transition who's
kind of like hard
cut um that's really bad aw da ting oh
yeah that's that's immediately a problem
they can fix that stuff cool but this
game seems like it'll be good outside of
VR anyway like that's just sort of the
icing on the cake as long as it doesn't
get rancid and that's the challenge
though because like producer kawada was
saying at Gamescom that it's an obvious
quote like you're never going to please
one hundred percent of the people but in
this case specifically you have those
people that have been around since
resident 123 I don't like you know like
the ones that people usually came on for
whenever we're ready to walk away from
the series there are people that are
more excited for resonable to remake
because that's a shirt that's not even a
sure thing because that's an entirely
like remade game whereas like you know
like remake the gamecube game was
already made by a team that worked on
the original but then you have the camp
that was introduced with four which is
an iconic like third person action game
how do you kind of merge those two camps
with seven do you have to and how do you
actually bring them into the present and
I know that the team is very cognizant
of the fact that they're not going to do
that completely and I hope that they
just don't worry about that that much
and like definitely like convey the res
evil vibes that i'm looking for like you
said the inventory management like that
kind of getting a sense of space and
ownership over this mansion or wherever
you're going to be in and then I like
the structure of it already I guess like
the bigger picture things has yet to be
seen hopefully we'll see more before
January but I don't know like I'm
optimistic about it but I don't know you
said like the VR definitely exacerbated
the tension of everything yeah and just
hearing you guys talk makes me wonder
like what does this like cat-and-mouse
type of ailment like how does it
actually like transfer into the rest of
the game like how can you hit up your
inventory when you're constantly being
chased well that's that's just a right
it could be part of the whole cassette
structure where this is just literally a
slice which I kind of hope what an
excellent opportunity to experiment with
all sorts of different types of horror
Yeah right they could just run the gamut
of you know these great sort of horror
period items over the last few decades
from film with in this game and like
that in gaming as well and so yeah I
think that's how that's probably going
to exist I mean they're literally
cassette tapes drawing the comparison to
VHS the movie is that I think there's
three the found footage and that's like
those short stories contain on the tapes
are these like throw it not throw away
those are these like kind of ancillary
segments that don't relate to the main
game maybe narrative Lee but
mechanically they could be completely
different which will be all
because then you get this little like
bite-sized kind of breath of fresh air
from like maybe the overarching kind of
system you've figured out and that
that's like what intrigues me most I
hope they like really go for that
structure what if some of them are like
super light hearted tapes we're just
like participating in like something
before the chaos and the horror maybe
like ants like the Baker's before they
became like the psychos that they showed
and that's real interesting or maybe
there's like one we're like they just
finished eating your legs and you are
going out of the building a great that
it was just a 12 second segment just
screaming oh oh my legs you still know
what that finger does in beginning our
demo the toilet time you can put it on
that hand the mannequin figure but like
they keep saying there's a purpose of it
but it's probably just sticking balloons
that's what that's exactly what i was
thinking or that are like kind of like
plugging a hole in a wall there's an axe
as well they I think they include the
axe just to hint that there's gonna be
weapons but that's the most subtle hint
ever because this is the first demo they
ever released for the game and I think
it's still sitting like at the highest
most downloaded ps4 demo ever it was
that like three million last time we
checked the head two million back in
June but yeah I don't know it's it's I'm
very intrigued and excited about the
game as a rims evil fan and as just
someone who likes horror games in
general and I'm out last to being pushed
back to what I believe is going to be
after this now mmm that's kind of making
a way for our last two a little easier
i'd say anyway cool let us know what you
think about res evil 7 biohazard in the
comments below it'll be out in January
24th i believe for ps4 xbox one pc